Yeah. So, the Islamic Golden Age, well,
there's kind of two. And the one is the
Abbassads in Baghdad. And this is the
the Abbassid um empire starts after the
Umayads. And the Umiads are like so
around 750. Usually the Abbassad golden
age would be sometime after 800.
>> Okay. And this is Haron Rasheed who's
now allied with or on friendly terms
with Charlemagne. But there's also a
supposed golden age in Spain, Umayad,
Spain in Cordova. And what what needs to
be understood about the golden age is
this. Um let me try to start off by
giving you an analogy, right? I I forget
which country which Arab country or you
know in the Gulf which is the one that
has those skyscrapers that everyone
>> Dubai Dubai UA Yeah. Okay. Imagine, you
know, many many, let's say, decades or
centuries from now, those buildings are
still standing there and, you know, the
whole everything's changed and, you
know, Islam maybe is gone or whatever.
And, um, people look at it and go, "Wow,
that was a golden age, that country,
that civilization, because look what it
led to."
>> Now, we would say, well, no, I mean,
they had their Islam, sure, but this is
actually money and Westerners built it.
western technology, western workers, and
it just so happened that these Arabs had
the money to spend on it. That I submit
to you is the best way to understand the
golden age that happened historically.
It didn't happen due to anything to do
with Islam. Quite the contrary, it
happened despite Islam. Okay? And it was
basically so let's uh if we go to the
Abbassid, as I was telling you, which is
the primary golden age, um this is now
okay. So now the Abbassad Empire is more
Persianized and it's it's in it's in
Baghdad. Okay. It's and it's it's
heavily Persianized. Keep in mind when
these Arab Muslim conquests happen, most
of so let's say Egypt and Syria which
were highly Christian. Let's say in the
8th century, 9th century, 10th century,
they're still majority Christian.
>> Mhm.
>> And there's Jews also as well,
especially in Alexandria and various
cities. And you have a lot of
Zorastrians and Persia. Okay. You have
all these different groups who are
living underneath now Islamic rule.
They're the ones who are doing all the
stuff that we call the golden age, okay?
It's Christians, it's Jews, and and
especially it's Persians in the Abbassad
era. And it's not because of anything
special about Islam. I mean, they are
literally not Muslims and and a few of
them who are are literally like they
just converted. They're first generation
converts, which means they're still
primarily whatever their former religion
was. So, the best that you can say is
that the Muslims uh you know uh
sponsored it, maybe paid for it. Okay.
But it there was nothing intrinsic to
Islam. And once Islam started to harden
because even at this time the Abbassad
caliphate in the golden age, there's
still debates uh between the various
schools of Islamic law. And there's some
that were actually considered liberal,
you know, to if we can use that term. Um
but by I forget the exact time,
something like in the 10th century,
what's known as uh the doors of
Ishtahed. Ishtad was a way for the
liberals to get around draconian Islam.
And the the saying is the doors were
closed and basically the hardliners won
the Islamic debate and now if anything
all that stuff started dwindling away.
Okay. So it was never because of Islam
but there was a time where Islam in its
early national period was you can say
liberal enough to allow this sort of
thing to happen. But the people who were
doing the achievements were actually not
Muslims. And if they were they were like
literally just converted to join the
winning crowd like a lot of people did
over the years. and their mind and the
way they thought and their heritage was
still non-Muslim. So that's why I give
you that analogy you know of yeah Saudi
Arabia and these places if you look at
their world view their culture which is
based on Islam well yeah it's draconian
Sharia law living in a desert polygamy
etc etc but they have wealth and look at
what they can have and they can build
skyscrapers they can have the greatest
stuff that westerners can't have that
doesn't mean it's actually part and
parcel of Islam
>> so that's uh the best way I think to
understand